à l'emplacement de cette croix les 14 et
21 octobre 1793 ont été exécutés 19
montagnon pour leur participation à
l'épisode insurrectionnel et
contre-révolutionnaire de la petite vend
des conventions
que l'amendé soit détruite
[Musique]
en faire
en immense si le tchèque
l'expression de petites vendée désigne
cette insurrection de septembre à
octobre 1793 qui se déroule dans le
plateau de maîche le russe et jusqu à
orchamps vennes la région de vercel il
faut savoir qu'il y a plusieurs vendée
qui éclate en france dans l'année 1793
dans un contexte bien particulier à
savoir celui du durcissement de la
révolution avec la mise en place d'un
régime d'exception qui est la terreur le
haut doubs particulièrement la franches
montagnes est une frontière religieuse
où s'est développé au cours des siècles
un catholicisme de réaction
particulièrement offensif et donc à ce
titre là ils vont percevoir les mesures
de laïcisation de déchristianisation de
la révolution comme autant de menaces et
ce qui va mettre le feu aux poudres
c'est le 23 août 1793 les frontières
sont menacés par des troupes coalisées
et la convention va multiplier des
réquisitions parmi la population faire
des levées en masse les hommes de 25 à
30 ans veuf et célibataires doivent
partir au combat
dans la nuit du 31 août au 1er septembre
une réunion clandestine a lieu à 100 c
et montagnon vont marcher sur
baume-les-dames dans l'espoir de
récupérer des armes à la suite de cela
il est prévu une attaque de la garnison
de pierre fontaine toujours dans le
souci de récupérer des armes mais le 5
septembre
cette attaque de pierre fontaine est un
véritable échec
le 6 au matin les troupes
révolutionnaires les attendent au lieu
dit le grand communal à bonnétage éclate
alors une fusillade qui fera une
vingtaine de morts parmi les montagnes
ans dans les jours qui suivent le
tribunal révolutionnaire va juger 494
dossier et le verdict est sans appel
quarante trois condamnations à la peine
de mort dont les dix neuf martyrs de
mèches 46 peines d'emprisonnement sur
des longues durées vingtaine de
déportation en guyane et il y aura
d'autres peines comme des peines
d'humiliation publique
c'est dire que ici à mèche en octobre
1793 s'est joué un morceau majeur dans
la répression de la petite wendel
[Musique]
en 1857 le comte charles de montalembert
chantre du catholicisme libéral et
député du doubs va offrir à l'église de
mèches cette plaque de marbre noir à la
mémoire des 19 guillotine est de mèche à
cette plaque est dédié à tous les morts
pour la foi catholique dans le texte et
non c'est que charles de montalembert
lourd a souvent la montagne chrétienne
pour reprendre ses propres propos ce qui
est intéressant c'est que l'on connaît
bien là le profil social de ces
personnes
sur les dix-neuf guillotine et 11 sont
des cultivateurs trois sont des
journaliers et par ailleurs il y à un
cordonnier un meunier et un instituteur
donc c'est vraiment cette petite bande
est l'expression d'une base populaire
le rôle des prêtres réfractaires ceux
qui refusent de prêter serment à la
constitution civile du clergé est
essentielle ils vont organiser des
messes blanche autrement dit des messes
clandestine dans des lieux de refuge au
fond des forêts nous comme ici près de
fournet-blancheroche dans un lieu-dit
baptisée chez nobis danse et metz on va
assister à une véritable émulation pour
propager l'esprit de la contre
révolution
et donc c'est l'une des composantes clés
de la petite vendait beaucoup de textes
ont été écrits en glorifiant je cite les
martyrs de maîche et dans cet esprit-là
des pièces de théâtre comme la
guillotine ont été interprétés à mèche
en juin 1948 en ce lieu se déroule une
fois par an une messe du souvenir en
hommage au rôle de ces prêtres
réfractaires et au martyre de 1793
cela montre bien cette importance du
devoir de mémoire catholique dans notre
franches montagnes
[Musique]